on passe maintenant à notre terrienne du
samedi soir
[Musique]
nami bonsoir
alors ne me c'est le nom que vous portez
dans les 140 films x que vous avez
interprété pour l'état civil votre
prénom c'est isabelle alors pourquoi
cette carrière dans le cinéma porno à
cause d'une princesse saoudienne qui
vous a séquestré pendant des mois vous
racontez votre histoire dans un livre
intitulé
totalement dévoilée publié chez
pygmalion
[Musique]
vous êtes né
25 juillet 1969 à saint quentin
en picardie
alors enfant vous manqué d'amour vous
manquez de tendresse un petit break mère
était très bigote c'est ça exactement
puis on était une famille nombreuse dont
kiel effet difficile à mon avis de
s'occuper de tout le monde de la même
façon elle s'occupait beaucoup des plus
petits très jeune vous remarqué que vous
faite de l'effet aux hommes en école
vous ennuie beaucoup vous préférez la
danse vous rêvez en petit rat aller
notre petit rat de l'opéra il cite à 11
ans que vous connaissez isabelle votre
premier orgasme en montant sur une corde
à noeuds d'où le nom
alors c'est notre grand oncle qui va
prolonger ce premier émoi la nuit il se
glisse dans votre vie et vous caresse et
finalement vous recevez en fin de
l'affection et par rapport à lass
l'affection que vous en avez besoin et
vous acceptez ce assez facilement
finalement puis ça fait du bien je alors
ça dans ma tête d'enfant ça n'est pas
sexuel sont des guilis quatre ans plus
tard c'est un prêtre qui succède à votre
oncle il vous enseigne le français mais
il effleure aussi vos seins ça il
corrige mes fautes d'orthographe blanc
de dictée et passe sa main dans mon
corps sage mais l'homme qui compte le
plus c'est un autre oncle alors qu'il
s'appelle tonton bernard alors lui c'est
un homo d'abord discrets mais au mot
dandy extrêmement raffiné c'est lui en
fait qui vous fait progresser j'adore
naturel intellectuelle vous à pau on
apprend à bien me tenir à table voilà
c'est le bon angle de la famille en fait
contre en 1985 ze16 en fait l'amour pour
la première fois avec sébastien ouais
les instances au camping d'allevard en
isère en savoie
voilà c'est bien le bas
hélas alors là ici la voix oui la
direction du camping d'allevard oppose
un démenti formel à boé négation
là vous vous montrez déjà très soumises
vous faites tout ce qu'il veut c'est
bastien ouais c'est vrai parce que je me
déjà c'est ma première fois donc je suis
quand même un peu timide on va dire et
puis que c'est certainement des
expériences précédentes qui font que
quelque part j'avais l'âge en
1988 je vous avais 19 ans vous rêvez
d'une autre vie vous vous imaginez
danseuses et vous quittez votre picardie
natale avec votre petite amie du moment
où sa peine stéphane direction calme à
lui c'est plutôt culturisme que culture
1 celui ci un oui c'est ça c'est le vrai
garçon quoi l'amour tous les motards et
là mesdames messieurs le destin
[Musique]
vous tombez sur une petite annonce
cherche professeurs pour donner des
cours de danse pendant six mois à des
enfants en arabie saoudite
vous répondez
vous êtes convoqué c'est ça convoqués ou
chez la princesse qui avait une villa à
cal quand elle vous ouvre la porte elle
vous demande de danse et oui c'est ça de
danse et de donner un cours de danse ça
se passe bien ça se passe très bien
d'autant plus que je me retrouve devant
une très jolie femme longue
d'ailleurs queue de cheval là vous vous
dites j'ai décroché le jackpot alors
j'ai pas jackpot mais en tout cas je
vais pouvoir faire ce dont j'ai envie je
vais pouvoir travailler enfin donner des
cours de danse voilà classique à 22 ans
vous prenez l'avion pour la première
fois pour vous envoler vers le pays
d'aladin en arrivant à ryad les autres
femmes du voyage ont disparu vous vous
retrouvez non voilée au milieu d'hommes
et à ce moment là il ya un moutawa tu es
dans la police religieuse d'arabie
saoudite qui vous tombe dessus avec n ah
oui oui oui bien sûr je n'avais pas de
voile moi je ne savais pas qu'il fallait
être voilés je suis parti normalement
comme donc nous tahoua vous tombe dessus
vous vous retrouvez dans une petite
pièce de l'aéroport enfermez vous êtes
en panique et là on vous ordonne de vous
couvrir et on vous confisque votre
passeport
ouais ça ça se passe comme ça donc on ne
pousse dans une petite pièce on me donne
un appel une abaya un voile on ne
m'explique pas comment m donc je le mets
sur mes cheveux on me dit qu'on doit pas
voir mes
poignets mais mes chevilles en a rien à
voir on est loin des mille et une nuits
quand même on est loin du dieu de la
danse du ventre
alors vous commencé à flipper c'est en
arrivant au palais des rameuses
princesse une chambre à c'est un grave
bien loin de vos rêves vous rêviez de
tapis de jasmin de merde oui vous rêviez
de lorient
mais pas du tout je me retrouve dans une
chambre plus que médiocre un petit lit
un petit lavabo douche ou l'autre jaune
ces salles il ya ce qu'on appelle les
arômes et ya c'est à dire des espèces 2
du gros lézard à l'intérieur la porte
claque dans votre dos vous allez rester
enfermé pendant des jours sans
information sans contact juste un garde
qui nous apporte de temps en temps on ne
vous dit rien
on ne dit rien et donc le seul contact
que j'avais c'était effectivement une
grosse main qui cogne à ma porte et qui
dépose un plateau sur le sur le
pas-de-porte parce que ce qu'ils avaient
sur le plateau à y avait un espèce
d'oiseau bouyer lors c'était tous les
jours la même chose une espèce de
moineaux bouillie une espèce de petite
salade non assaisonné de tomates
et de poivrons et du riz de temps en
temps à écosser en plus
donc j'ai touché de porter la bannière
en plus je suis obligé de porter la
bayard mais dans ma chambre je ne la
portait par la foule à force d'être
enfermé jo ann hui vous vous résignez à
la docilité ils ont subi c'est votre
situation de pauvreté pas tellement de
moyens de l'être en sortir faut bien
dire les choses voilà un jour vous
pouvez sortir pour les remplir votre
gros dos à la fontaine et vous tombez
sur quatre algérienne prisonnière com -
vous dites quoi là elles me disent alors
elle parle français et ils me disent
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là si tu peux
partir maintenant par est-ce que tu
encore ton se passe ton passeport si tu
as ton passeport et c'est de partir
sinon tu ne rentrera jamais oh
voilà et ensuite elles sont bons parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas rester très
longtemps autour de moi tous en
comprenons de l'ol aussi donc c'était
une conversation
un peu cachée et d'ailleurs je ne les ai
jamais revus
parce que je pense que soient elles ont
été dénoncées soit quelqu'un les avis
alors les jours passent dans ce cas
rabat sérail baptisé centre de beauté
jusqu'au jour où vous rencontrez la
fameuse princesse
alors cette princesse est la troisième
épouse la plus jeune la plus jolie la
préférée d'un vieux prince
assez repoussant le prince je ne les ai
jamais vus mais on m'en a parlé moi je
ne les ai jamais vu effectivement
c'était un homme qui apparemment avait
71 ans à l'époque elle en avait 26 ou 27
et nous fait signe quand même un peu la
princesse non oui elle me fascine parce
que parce que déjà je ne retrouve plus
du tout la même personne
line porte l'abaya elle porte le voile
elle corrompt dans les mains est le lait
très stoïque très dur aussi dans son
regard le contraire de ce que j'avais vu
en france
mais elle me fascine aussi elle vous
fascine vous êtes un peu comme dans le
temps le syndrome de stockholm la ville
jean qui aime son bourreau quoi oui
parce que je me mets aussi à sa place
j'ai de l'empathie bizarrement donc je
me mets aussi à sa place et je me dis
mais qu'elle lui quelle vie est là cette
femme est quelque part elle sa haine de
l'être humain c'est sûr nous qu'elle l'a
alors elle vous explique que vous avez
donné des cours de danse trois heures
par jour avant le goûter à des jeunes
princesses saoudiennes
la routine s'installe votre désespoir se
creuse alors là vous sympathisez donc
avec des indiennes qui travaillent dans
les cuisines et un prof de piano
philippe rey lui les homosexuels et
d'ailleurs mais lui il sort la nuit il
est ce que la culture
sauf qu'un jour il revient pas
alors soit il a été prise c'est pareil
soit il a été dénoncée mais
effectivement il disparaît ouais et là
miracle
une élève libanaise de 14 ans ouais
acceptent d'envoyer vos lettres à votre
famille et finalement l'ambassade de
france finit par intervenir et s'en
occuper et après
299 jours de séquestration vous êtes
libérés c'est ça un garde bien frapper à
ma porte et me dit il ya là il ya là bas
la francia voilà
merci la france l'a quand même
merci la france merci maman aussi
simplement oui parce que les parents
voilà s'inquiéter quand même un peu
alors arrivée à l'aéroport charles de
gaulle saoudien vous rend votre
passeport ciel jusque là vous n'aviez
plus de passeport et vous partez à nice
rejoindre la vôtre ex jules stéphane
ouais c'est ça alors j'arrive à nice et
je pars sur cannes parce que j'avais
laissé mon petit copain à l'époque sur
cannes voilà sauf qu'il n'est plus là du
tout je les laissais oui le ses fans il
faut dire il à vider votre compte en
banque il a pris le pognon que la
saoudienne vous avez donné et un jour il
ya une gonzesse qui vous appelle en vous
disant tu sais que ton mec te trompes
ans que stéphane
là vous glandez quelques semaines a
sommé par les antidépresseurs
jusqu'au jour où le destin frappe à
nouveau
[Musique]
un photographe vos remarques et vous
poser pour ce photographe dvq
amateurs amateurs ça me plaît de poser
nue
oui
je me dévoile enfants et enfin je me
sens libre ouais aimé et regarder alors
un peu plus tard un agent vous propose
de devenir gogo dance
et en
1997 donc vous avez 28 ans vous exécutez
des strip-teases à cannes pour le
festival du x les fameux hot d'or et là
vous basculé dans un autre monde un
monde le monde du porno qui vous séduit
instantanément vous dites je venais de
trouver mon peuple et ça exactement
pourtant je ne n'avais jamais regardé de
films porno je connaissais absolument
pas ce milieu mais voilà j'ai les portes
se sont ouvertes quelque part et je me
suis je me suis retrouvé chez moi ah non
plus tard vous participez à votre
premier tournage donc là adieu isabelle
nomi aînés ne mélissa votre nombre de
cinémas le succès est au rendez-vous et
là bizarrement votre père vous encourage
une tape sur l'épaule et mini alors il
paraît que tu fais du cinéma et j'ai dit
oui papa il m'a simplement dit ma fille
fait attention à ta santé et avec un
large sourire c'est pas de
l'encouragement dit ne t'inquiète pas je
t'aime quoi que tu fasses bien
le cuir
c'est votre mère un jour vous demande
une photo dédicacée pour une amie à elle
pour une amie elle et son chef de
service je crois qu'ils lui avaient
montré des photos de ses filles parce
qu'elle a quatre fig il a dit mais celle
ci ouais la connais et oui là vous
rejoignez les productions marc dorcel
newey vous gagnez bien votre aussi fait
un peu des fois de freelance en privé
quoi bien et un jour vous êtes invités
dans une soirée on y revient dans une
soirée à las vegas avec
[Musique]
avec eminem est oui alors ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'il nous a pas touchés
ils passent la soirée à jouer à la
playstation vita il est là avec ses
potes et il est venu piocher quelques
actrices hausses allant du xe qui se
passait à ce moment-là avec gas et et
voilà bonjour s'amusant bonjour baby
foot enfin voila c'est alors vous serez
nomistes hardwicke jusqu en 2014 et là
vous arrêter vous reconvertissent et
dans l'immobilier
pourquoi l'immobilier parce que c'est ce
qui est arrivé en fait encore d'unité
ouais voilà j'ai une bonne étoile ouais
vraiment ouais je sais mais aujourd'hui
vous gérez vais bien aujourd'hui jérémy
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu